a lot of kids dream about becoming
Disney stars but is the Disney contract
worth all the strict rules stay tuned to
find out why Disney stars never seem to
age are you new around here don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content like this social media in the
world of social media almost everyone is
on at least one platform and that goes
double for stars part of their fame is
them promoting themselves on social
media but a lot of stars aren't free to
do what they want on their pages in fact
some Disney stars have even said that
their posts have to be approved before
they go out publicly while filming
struck - Cameron Diaz and Mike Myers
weren't allowed to reveal anything about
the movie because of this there was a
social media clause in their contracts
and this wasn't a one-time thing lots of
stars have social media clauses in their
contracts if you think about it it makes
sense that producers and directors would
want to keep tabs on what people posts
so that fans don't find out too many
details about the film or show early but
with Disney it's a little more intense
Disney tries to keep the squeaky clean
image so for them it's not very
beneficial to have a young star who is
reckless on social media they need to be
able to make sure that their brand is
not going to be tarnished by a star
posting something strange on social
platforms so while social media clauses
can be pretty strict it's pretty smart
of Disney to include them rights to
their name as a star your name is
everything it's what people know you by
and how they can place you but sometimes
stars don't actually own their names
you're probably wondering what we are
talking about let's take a look at Miley
Cyrus for instance on her hits show
Hannah Montana she agreed to have the
main character be named - Miley as well
at the time she probably didn't think
anything of it she probably was excited
to have her name be made famous but as
Miley later realized this meant that
Disney owned their rights to the name
Miley can you imagine not owning your
own name it's basically a birthright but
when you don't have a lawyer
when you were signing those duty papers
you are liable for anything to happen
after the name mishap Miley's mom
decided to hire a lawyer to make sure
that her daughter was protected going
forward
so in Miley's case everything turned out
fine but think about other stars how
many other stars have their real names
as the name of the character on their
show there is no way to really know
without looking into all of their
contracts but we can bet that that's the
case how to talk as if losing the rights
to your name isn't enough that's just
the tip of the iceberg as to what Disney
stars have to go through Disney tries to
control almost every aspect of their
stars especially when the actresses or
actors are first breaking onto the scene
this is true even down to the stars
voices you may be asking yourself how
Disney could control someone's voice it
may seem impossible but Disney always
binds away take bella thorne
as an example you may remember her from
her stint on shake it up while she was
on the show Disney tried to really
control her public persona they felt
that she would appeal to Disney fans
more if she spoke in a higher-pitched
falsetto during her interviews this was
a way to ensure that she would give off
a more clean goody-two-shoes vibe in the
beginning she followed along with
Disney's rules as most stars do after a
while though
being fake got old and she decided to be
herself now Bella does what she wants
and has landed other television deals
outside of Disney we wonder how she
feels now that she is free of all the
restrictions of Disney and all that came
with them music when Disney stars are
allowed to speak it's usually about
something that has already approved and
more times than not it's through music
seriously have you ever wondered why so
many of your favorite Disney stars all
of the sudden want to transition into
music it's because it's greatly
encouraged waits encouraged might be
putting it too lightly it's pretty much
pushed on them and even though they do
agree to go into music it's not at all
what it's cracked up to be
apparently Disney keeps a pretty close
watch on any music that their stars
produce and that include
the lyrics the Jonas Brothers said that
back when they were huge Disney stars
who were forced to change any lyrics
that seemed too risque joe said that
even saying that he was alone in a room
with another person was unacceptable to
Disney can you imagine writing music
lyrics with those kinds of crazy
restrictions it must have been super
hard to create under so much pressure
eventually the Jonas Brothers with their
separate ways and decided to make music
for themselves and do what they wanted
their music is definitely a lot more
risque but also so so good salary
negotiations when you think of Disney
stars you probably think that they make
so much money right isn't that what
being on television means well not in
all cases
apparently Disney stars are not really
allowed to negotiate their contracts
very much we are sure there is probably
some leeway in this rule for huge stars
but in the beginning negotiations are
not really encouraged or accepted don't
believe us
okay let's use Miley Cyrus as an example
though she was the star and namesake of
her show Hannah Montana she was actually
the lowest paid actor on the show which
just makes no sense right well she and
her parents didn't know what everyone
else was making initially which yielded
Miley to accepting a lot less for the
show than she should have looking back
on it
Miley says that she doesn't harbor any
resentment about the situation and just
says that at the time she didn't know
any better at least Miley went on to
become a big star in her own right and
probably makes more now than she ever
did with Disney but imagine all the
other Disney stars who were never able
to break out of the Disney mold are they
living off the tiny Disney paychecks
when they could be making more if they
went somewhere else
scandal classes think about how many
stars Disney has a ton right now take a
second to think about how many scandals
involve Disney stars not so many have
you ever wondered why that is
well when Disney invests money in a star
they are really thorough what we mean by
this is that they make their stars take
courses in scandal management and so
for media when you think about it that
might not actually be the worst idea
these kids are usually pretty young so
being thrust into fame can be a big deal
for a lot of them a course on how to
manage yourself on social media and what
to do if you find yourself in a scandal
could be pretty beneficial just think
about your own personal life how helpful
would a course like that be to you
probably extremely helpful so we don't
necessarily blame Disney for this
stipulation stars need to be prepared
for whatever comes we just wonder how
much time does new stars have to spend
this training and how intense it is is
it monthly weekly or maybe even daily as
long as the class isn't too crazy or
intense it's probably super helpful to
the Stars non-competes
when someone is on a really big show are
in a very successful movie you start to
kind of associate them with their
character the thing is this phenomenon
is not a coincidence
in some cases actresses and actors are
not allowed to work on any other
projects while they are with Disney one
of the saddest cases of this was with
the Disney's Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs the movie was Disney's first ever
full-length movie that was animated so
we are really throwing it way back there
because it was the first film of its
kind Disney was dedicated to keeping the
movie magical for as long as possible
the actress who did the voice for Snow
White was adriana caselotti
Disney one and Adriana's voice to be
unique to Snow White so in her contract
they put in a clause that said she could
never take on any new projects after her
role as Snow White which means she
couldn't appear in TV or on film from
the nigh she couldn't even be on the
radio naturally her career was pretty
much at a standstill after that we
wonder what made her sign such a
ridiculous contract was it the lure of
being the first fully animated Disney
Princess but where's the price worth it
probably not know smoking when you look
at Disney stars you may see regular kids
with crazy good looks but Disney sees
them as role models which is probably
why they want their stars to be squeaky
clean and buy squeaky clean we
that even a five-year-old should be able
to watch anything that they produce this
is probably why Disney stars are not
allowed to smoke in any Disney films
this also includes Disney related films
with Lucasfilm Pixar and Marvel any film
that Disney has anything to do with
cannot feature smoking on screen this
role was announced in 2015 by chairman
and CEO Bob Iger because he didn't want
Disney films or the actors in them to
become bad influences on younger
audiences there are only a few
exceptions to this rule
one is if the movie is depicting a
historical figure who is known to have a
serious smoking habit then the actor
actress would be allowed to smoke on
film before the span about 43 percent of
Marvel films showed character smoking so
this is a huge change so far as rules go
this one is pretty beneficial a lot of
kids do actually look up to Disney and
it stars so forbidding Disney stars to
smoke on screen can only help the little
kids watching morality what is the
common thread that links all Disney
stars together during the height of
their careers we'll give you a guess got
it yet it's their squeaky-clean personas
how did they all get this way no it's
not because Disney scours churches and
honor roles to find the most perfect
kids to work for them it's because
Disney pretty much includes it in
everyone's contracts it's called the
morality clause which basically means
that Disney can drop them at any time if
they are found to be caught in the
middle of a scandal that would bring
their name and Disney's name into a bad
light which if you think about it is
enough to scare most kids into
submission though this clause is in most
people's contracts Disney does not
always go through with it
remember when Vanessa Hudgens had some
not so suitable for kids images released
a while back that would have been enough
for them to drop her but in the end
Disney decided to keep Vanessa though it
worked out for Vanessa the constant loom
of a sudden end to your
contract should you do anything out of
line is enough to keep most people doing
whatever Disney says look like a kid by
now you have probably realized that most
Disney stars are a lot older than the
characters that they play on television
and even when that isn't the case stars
don't seem to age too much from what
they are when we first see them appear
on our screens coincidence we think not
it's another rule that ZZ stars
half-living 5 if you are a male and play
in a younger character many times you
will be forced to cut any facial hair
that you have and you won't be allowed
to let it grow back Joe Jonas wrote in
an essay for vulture that he had to
shave every day so that he could pretend
to be 16 who is actually 20 years old
even the girls aren't really allowed to
outgrow their characters many times they
are instructed to keep their nails short
and in moderate colors as to not look
too rebellious or risque who look Disney
as an older is a part of life it's not
natural for people to be 16 forever and
it's actually kind of soupy for 25
year-olds to be running around
pretending to be teenagers that people
age for goodness sakes and that's it for
10 strict rules Disney Channel stars
must follow were you surprised by any of
the rules let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
[Music]